there's plenty of horror movies that
start slowly and methodically letting
viewers settle into a rhythm before the
terror really comes these are not those
movies here are the scariest opening
scenes in horror movies Friday the 13th
part 5 a new beginning
other Friday the 13th sequels Lienhard
in the funhouse territory relying just
as much on morbid humor as gory shots
but not in the case of Friday the 13th
part 5 a new beginning
Corey Feldman reprises his role as a
young Tommy Jarvis in the dream sequence
that opens the film on a dark stormy
night Tommy finds himself observing
Jason's grave as two would-be grave
robbers are digging it up
[Music]
it doesn't go well and Feldman's
reactions as he witnesses Jason rising
once again to put you the hapless crooks
cell Tommy's sheer panic and terror
perfectly
the brilliant opening is arguably the
best of the series Twilight Zone
the movie 1983's Twilight Zone film was
largely short of true scares but it's
brief Creek credits opening sequence has
added a phrase to the pop-culture
lexicon that still has the power to make
our skin crawl hey you want to see
something really scary you bet
really yeah okay this is this is really
really scary now comedians dan Aykroyd
and Albert Brooks put the audience at
ease as motorists on a lonely road at
night but when Brooks tries to rattle
Aykroyd by turning off his headlights
Aykroyd ups the ante by insisting that
Brooks pull over so that he can show him
something scarier and boy does he ever
what'd he do scream Wes Craven's 1996
deconstruction of the horror genre
scream started a trend of self-awareness
and fright flicks that continues to this
day but it's easy to forget what a
virtuoso a piece of filmmaking its
opening sequences drew Barrymore appears
as a young woman named Casey who
receives what she thinks is a prank
phone call I don't think the guy quizzes
her about horror movies the tone of the
call goes from playful to sinister to
outright terrifying as Casey slowly
realizes this is no joke why do you want
to know my name
what did you say the scene is an
absolute master class in playing on
audience expectations and building
tension
screams influence is towered over horror
for the last couple of decades but it
may not have lingered quite as long in
the popular imagination without this
open jaws virtually everything that
could have gone wrong with jaws did up
to and including the mechanical sharks
not working up to expectations but the
technical problems ended up enhancing
the film in ways nobody could have
foreseen as Steven Spielberg wisely
chose to keep his toothy Menace
off-screen whenever possible the opening
scene shows just how effective this
technique is as a young swimmer named
Chrissy goes in for the last moonlit
skinny dip she'll ever take for the
actual attack Spielberg and his crew
employed an underwater system of ropes
to jerk the actress back and forth and
all we can see are her terrified
reactions which she completely sells
jaws is a film that set the template for
the summer tentpole picture and has been
ripped off more times than can be
counted but its opening retains all of
its power over four decades later drag
me to hell Sam Raimi made his triumphant
return to gonzo horror with 2009's
dragged me to hell the story of a lone
officer named Christine who runs afoul
of a curse unless she can find a way to
stop it Christine will be tormented by a
demon for three days before getting
dragged to hell
the opening scene makes it clear that
it's definitely not just in Christine's
head either a young boy is brought to a
medium because he's been hearing voices
after he stole a necklace for an old
woman all of the old evil dead ask Raimi
calling cards make their return the
off-kilter angles the eye-popping
close-ups the crazily kinetic camera
work but the scene also establishes that
the demon has no mercy as the boys
frantic cries for help
don't stop his fate
[Music]
[Music]